welcome back to on S we still with me is
the CEO and co-founder of the daily wi
Jeremy boring I'm joined by my pack the
author and socialist Grace Blakeley a a
contribut to Paul R Adrian and the
journalist and author Hillary Freeman
who I'll come to all three of you in a
moment Jeremy I just want to talk to you
just pivot slightly I read a column of
the New York Post yesterday about this
kind of faral situation in America where
universities like Harvard who were
literally just named the worst school in
America for failure to exercise free
speech on campus now saying that the
reason they allowed their students to
all sign this absurdly offensive letter
in the immediate aftermath of these
attacks effectively siding with Hamas uh
was because of their Devotion to free
speech and the reason I think it's
relevant for you to answer that is I
know that you as a company you're
producing your own children's content to
counter the left and woke propaganda and
so on so it kinds to me there's a
there's a neat link here but what do you
make of what's been happening in these
universities in America well I think
that the universities are in many ways
victims of their own rhetoric one of the
dangerous things to do in life is to say
things out loud because pretty soon
you'll have to defend them and soon
after that you'll start to believe them
and Harvard has been preaching this sort
of intersectional hierarchy now for at
least a decade and maybe more the
problem with the intersectional
hierarchy is that someone has to be on
the bottom in the in the sort of name of
equality or fostering some sort of
better sense of equality they've created
a situation where you know people who
they see as having been historically
places of power now are at the very
bottom and have been completely
dehumanized and one of the funny quirks
is they think that that is sort of
anti-majoritarian
anti-patriarchy you know in America it's
anti-christian white male in
particular and that it protects
minorities but of course one of the
smallest minorities in the world is the
Jews and unfortunately in every other
way they seem to fit more in positions
of power they tend to excel academically
they tend to excel in business they're
disproportionately represented in media
in education in science you know in
traditionally white collar and
governmental type roles and so the
intersectional hierarchy being preached
by these schools has left them in a
position where you know the most
probably hard done by minority of the
20th and 21st century somehow has been
dehumanized by them they don't know how
to get out of the way of their own bad
thinking there was actually a professor
at Cornell who was called on camera
doing
this
I think we have it Hamas shifted the
balance of power
yes Hamas has
punctured the
illusion of invincibility yeah that's
what they've done it was
exhilarating
resist it was exhilarating it was
energizing exhilarating and energizing
that's a professor at a top American
University I found that completely
shocking a that he would have that
thought process but B he would be so
brazenly free to do it in public like
that well sure I mean if what that
Professor had said instead is that
gender and biological sex are
inextricably linked he'd be out on the
streets by now and never work again
instead he says that it's exhilarating
to watch children murdered in their
homes because of some sort of bizarre
academic theory about power structures
here's the thing strength does not
necessarily connote virtue but strength
also does not necessarily connote a lack
of virtue weakness does not confer upon
a person virtue any more than weakness
confers upon a person a lack of virtue
there are wonderful Jews in the world
and there are terrible Jews in the world
there are wonderful Muslims in the world
and there are terrible Muslims in the
world there are wonderful people in
positions of strength I think the West
has done a relatively extraordinary job
compared to other societies throughout
human history and there are terrible
people in positions of power we need
only looked at the ruling regime in
China among others to know that when you
into collectivism is you forget about
the individual right we know a lot of
this obviously starts from childhood you
as a company have decided to take on
this what you see as indoctrination by
the woke left of kids tell me just
briefly about that yeah well I think
that one of the things that we at the
daily wire feel is that childhood uh has
been sort of distorted on one hand we
have this University system as you were
just discussing then infantilize as
adults we refer to 23 year olds as
college kids and we treat them like that
like kids who aren't responsible who
have no agency who can't be held
accountable for their own actions on the
other hand we have actual children
actual kids and instead of letting them
live in a world of imagination and
adventure and joy and wonder we want to
use them as political props we want to
March them in our rallies uh we want to
hold them up as some sort of symbol of
the struggle against you know entrenched
power structures or whatever the the
invogue terms are and what we believe at
the daily wire is actually why don't we
let adults be adults including 23 year
olds and why don't we let children be
children and so we've launched this
initiative bent key which is our new
company our new app and it's just
entertainment for kids it's not overtly
political we're overtly political as a
company of course but our content at Ben
key is not it really is just a place
where kids can sit down actually enjoy
entertaining content and parents don't
have to worry about having these sort of
destructive ideas of the moment you know
Jeremy I've got four kids and I I say
hurrah to that honestly I do I'm sick
and tired of these kids getting grabbed
by people who think they know what's
best for what these kids should be
thinking and doing it's it's ridiculous
uh I've got to leave it there Jeremy
you've been brilliant thank you very
much indeed for rolling with the the
punches earlier you came on to talk
about this and we then brought you in to
respond to what Bassam mus said I think
that was important and I I really
appreciate thank you very much thank you
okay uh Hillary welcome first time we've
had you on um Bassam mus have very fired
up I mean a lot of people who are pro
Palestinian historic Ally are very fired
up about this tonight as we came on air
this as yet unverified in terms of who's
responsible but it's it the Hamas are
claiming uh that this is an Israeli air
strike on a hospital may have killed 500
people it comes back to proportion for
me what is the correct response to the
outrage of October the 7th I don't know
what the correct response is but I don't
believe that Israel would be stupid
enough to bomb a hospital the day before
for Biden can I just say Israel has
released a statement already saying that
they warned civilians to evacuate the
hospital PRI not true that's been that's
been taken down by Al jazer already it
wasn't true there's a lot of stuff
flying around there's a lot of people
putting videos they claim Hamas
misfiring a rocket others are saying
it's definitely Israeli I think we need
to wait for absolute Clarity on this
what is indisputable is a hospital has
been here and it appears hundreds and
hundreds of people have died it it feels
to me with President Biden arriving
tomorrow this is a bit of a game changer
yeah yeah which is why I don't believe
it was deliberate because it just seems
it just doesn't make sense that they
would do that but is it the kind of
thing which you would say that if you're
bombing the hell out of Gaza and this
happens is collateral damage and you
have to suck it up I don't think Israel
has ever targeted hospitals it would
always avoid hospitals if it possibly
could so no of course I don't think that
it's good to I mean Israel has already
targeted hospitals by saying that it was
shutting off power and water which
resulted in hospitals overflowing
patients that were effectively untreat
that was considered a war crime many
people have called that out a war crime
gra just to be clear the Reuters news
agency is now reporting comments from
the Israeli military saying it's
intelligence shows a Palestinian Islamic
Jihad group is responsible for the
hospital attack had a rocket barrage
from Gaza intended for Israel pass near
the Gaza hospital and it's here we don't
know you we don't
know let's talk about what we do know
shall we okay we know that the Israeli
state has committed war crimes we know
that they have instituted a basically a
regime of collective punishment we know
now that they've used white phosphorus
in uh civilian areas which is considered
a war crime we know that this comes on
the back of the brutalization for many
many years now of the
palestin is already
6,400 Palestinians have died inations
with tro since 2008 including 1,400
children we also know that Hamas just
perpetrated one of the worst Terror
attacks in modern history and the worst
attack on Jewish people since the
Holocaust I can answer your question I
can answer your question about
proportionality because international
law tells us what the answer is in
relation to proportionality it tells us
that we have a right to defend ourselves
it tells us that we have a right whilst
defending ourselves to ensure that the
outcome is Ultimate peace and that is
what as far as I'm concerned we have not
witnessed even in the minute that we've
been on and if and if we were to ensure
that the rule of law was applied which
is what I hope Joe Biden is going to be
um reinforcing when he visits and when
Rishi sunak visits I hope that that's
what they're going to refor this is
quite clearly though not what many
people within the Israeli government
want one Israeli Minister said that he
wanted to unleash a second NABA do you
guys know what that means you know what
the NABA was right the official position
of the Israeli state for a long time has
been there was no NABA there was no
catastrophe this didn't happen this
foundational act of violence that really
led up in many ways to the conflict
we're seeing today happen
is's minister of National Security
benier says that the only thing that
should enter Gaza until the hostages are
released are hundreds of tons of
explosives from the Israeli Air Force
not an ounce of humanitarian Aid now
that strikes me as a statement which
doesn't care about international law
clearly clearly right benav is appalling
and problem is another problem Netanyahu
has he's packed the cabinet for
political self expediency he's packed
the cabinet with a bunch of right-wing
Headbangers
been saying like this for a long time
this year absolutely and that is part of
the reason why this has happened um but
you can't blame Israel again for what
Hamas did it's again people trying to
blame Palestinians all Palestinians for
what Hamas has done that is what many
actually we've seen now IDF soldiers
we've seen people saying this is a war
with Palestinian Civ do you agree that
hamash should be removed P you know my
answer to that question and it's so
frustrating the way that whenever anyone
comes on these show and talks about
the horrendous loss of life that has
been inflicted on Palestinians for many
many years there's this idea there's
this idea that you can ask this question
should we condone Hamas should we
condone should we condone Hass and what
that
does remed breaks of course Hamas should
be removed nobody seriously doubt that
as soon as you respond to the question I
said Israel has committed war crimes and
you respond by saying should should we
remove the implication if we all agree
that H SYM my question is how do you
remove how what you okay well what do we
know about Hamas we know that actually
Netanyahu has said in the past that he
wanted to strengthen Hamas because that
was the only way that he could ever get
rid of the Palestinian State he has said
that outright we have evidence that he
knew about these Terror attacks Shin
knew about these we have we have
evidence that shinb said this was an
immense intelligence failure and that
was there was Intelligence that
suggested that this was going to happen
there no question who would allow this
to happen to his people there is abs you
know where that's a conspiracy theory
the head of shin said this was an
extraordinary as a Jewish person yeah
this has been a nightmare 10 days yes
but as a Palestinian person right now in
Gaza they're going through if they're an
innocent Palestinian civilian they are
going through do you feel empathy for
them I feel absolute empathy for them
and all the Jewish people I know nobody
wants Palestinian people to suffer
nobody does we want to get rid of Hamas
and we want our hostages back and so to
answer P's question how to REM move
Hamas is it going to happen by a ground
war is that I I think that that is the
only way you can possibly do it but the
consequences could be disastrous we've
got to leave it there we run out of time
thank you all very much
indeed